when you sit down to write something
you you understand that it's a journey
right
and for some people it's not about the
it's not about the destination it's just
the journey
how do you create a powerful and
meaningful story i think it first has to
be
powerful and meaningful to you
i i try to
now
as i write if i'm writing something that
i
story i just have to tell
it has to a lot of the time speak to
something maybe that i'm dealing with
myself
and
i get i can work through a lot of it in
the script
you know and i think that's why it wakes
me up because it's something that
i'm figuring out that i'm working
through and i'm working through it with
characters
so i think it starts there it has to be
important and impactful for you and from
there you can begin to shape it so that
it's something that is easily digestible
for somebody who's maybe not
experiencing the same things as you
or
you know they're not going on that same
journey with you
so you want to make it more relatable so
that you know they can certainly see
that journey and take that journey with
you
what if someone asked you to write a
screenplay and you know for hire and
it's not a story that necessarily you
tap into but you're being paid well and
you say all right i'll do it but you
just can't relate to the character to
the story to the theme to the tone
um
funny enough that just happened and
ultimately we long story short we just
couldn't work together that's just what
it was oh wow okay the
you know the story was just something i
can't relate to and
the way i would have to be able to tell
the story that other
person who was the financier
they didn't
they didn't want the story to go that
direction
so we were at an impasse
and we both had to say i don't think
this is going to work for either of us
because
what you want
won't wake me up in the middle of the
night
that message is not a message that
speaks to me
it's not a it's a throwaway message and
i wouldn't want to create something
that and spend months working on
something that i don't believe in
i just i wouldn't want to do that to
myself and i wouldn't want to do that to
someone who's paying me the money to do
it i just i think it's it's a bad idea
so yeah that actually happened to me
recently
and did you know fairly um soon into
your working with the person that this
wasn't going to work this was going to
happen
i didn't know it early enough
i
allowed us to go down the road too far
and waste a lot of each other's time
and
i normally don't consider something to
be a waste of time if i learn a lesson
but i think i learned i think i
understood things
far sooner and i just let it drag on
because i believed at some point
he would see what i was saying and as he
began to speak with his partners they
would see what i was saying
but unfortunately much like me he didn't
have
he did have partners but they were out
of the way they didn't have any
influence on the project so their
opinions didn't matter
so we're both people who don't report to
anybody
so we both you know we had to just shake
hands and say it's not going to work
that's fair yeah
it's better that you cut your ties then
than actually had it made and it wasn't
exactly what you felt
well i wouldn't have been able to write
it i just
i think that uh
when you when you sit down to write
something
you you understand that it's a journey
right
and for some people it's not about the
it's not about the destination it's just
the journey but i'm constantly keeping
both
in in mind the journey and the
destination journey and the destination
so
i know if this is the destination we
agreed to to get to this is the best
path
to tell the story
and if that doesn't work
and i see the alternative is a inferior
version to that then i i have to say i
don't think it's gonna click i don't
think it's really gonna click because
that journey won't tell it won't be
honest it won't be honest it's it's
it's forcing something you know
and um
i don't want to
say that but but it's just it becomes it
becomes like you're just pushing
constantly
and
trying to force something trying to
force a circle in a square hole and you
shouldn't do that when you're writing
especially in the beginning you
shouldn't do that when you're developing
the screenplay that's when it's fun and
that's when it's breezy
and if you can't see the journey in a
fun and breezy way
then it's time to kind of cut bait don't
don't spend so much time working on it
for something that's
it's not going to be fruitful for you
in the soul nor from an experience you
know
what are your thoughts on creating a
meaningful story versus one that's
commercial
i think it all depends on your goals
if your goal is to create something
commercial go for it i think that um
there's no
shortage
of
opportunities to create something
commercial
there's no shortage of it because
as you can see that's what's being
thrown at most of us all the time
something commercial that has mass
appeal and i think it's superficial i
think it's easy
um
you can take the money and run it's it's
what they call it legal bank robbery you
know it's
if that's your thing
i think that for
a lot of people who are not
for people who are driven by
quelling that voice inside
that won't really work
i think you're always going to have to
be making something meaningful whether
it's meaningful to you or meaningful to
audiences in general
because that's how you that's how you
you feed that thing inside of you right
um that need to get that that creativity
out you're creating creating something
that means something to you in that
moment
if you're constantly
if you are a person who desires to make
meaningful material
and you're constantly having to stuff
that down while you make something
commercial you're not living your best
life
you're not living your best life
and ultimately that's all we want to do
that's all we want to do as artists is
live our best life create stuff and get
it out there and then create something
again and get it out there and for for a
great number of people creating
something commercial is great
you you go out there it takes you maybe
a couple weeks of work and
it's off you know because when it a lot
of the times for especially for the
stuff now that's like your marvels and
you know anything that's disney related
and it's high concept those guys have a
paint by number formula
you can stack all those movies one on
top of the other and they'll hit the
same beats all the way through
and
you know that's good that's awesome they
know what their audiences want
and those writers have an easy job they
know by this moment this needs to happen
by this moment this needs to happen
if that feeds their soul or their bank
account
i say power to them hopefully it does
both hopefully does both
but if you desire to make meaningful
content you really have to get that out
even if it's if you're a writer it's
just writing the script
just purging it getting it out of your
system
and then you turn around and you write
something commercial but you have to get
out of your system you have to feed that
beast